[Music]
so Wolfgang helpfully laid out the
dichotomy between industry people and
academics and experimentalists and
computational people and if you're
wondering which one I am the answer is
yes so this is I'm going to mostly
describe work that happened in my lab at
Harvard and work by Bill Lauder who is
actually in industry at us doing a
start-up because that's what everyone
does these days but I recently also took
a gig as the director of a new MIT IBM
collaboration a quarter-million-dollar
AI Institute so if you if you're
interested in that come and find me
and then I'm going to tell you about
some deep learning work we've done but
then I'm also going to tell you at the
end if I have time about some
experimental work that it's inspired in
my lab just to kind of reinforce this
idea that there's sort of a loop that we
can be driving between models and
experiments so we all know that deep
learning has kind of a maybe kind of
connection to biology so we have units
and they have synapses and connections
between them okay that's that's part of
it that's for their artificial neural
network part comes from and then they're
deep and you know we know that
perceptual hierarchies for instance in
the and the primate are are sort of deep
hierarchical systems and deep CN n sort
of capture that but really when you get
right down to it you know that's been
most of the interplay between these two
and I think a lot of us here are sort of
trying to think well how can we go back
to the brain and get more inspiration
but then also how can we use the in you
know the deep learning to actually help
us understand the brain a little bit
better so again this virtuous loop
you're gonna hear this I think again and
again and again and that's that's
wherever we're coming from so it turns
out the deep learning so I'm interested
in perception so a different part of the
stack then the the previous two talks
imaged in how we perceive objects and
make sense of this sort of terrible
complicated flow of information coming
in through our senses and it turns out
that by accident deep learning systems
convolution neural networks turned out
to be the best model for doing this so
people have built all kinds of
computational models of how visual
processing worked in the ventral visual
pathway and primates but it turns out
that when you just started training deep
Nets
you just took the internal
representations compare them to actual
neuronal population responses and that's
the best model so so here this is a
paper from my my former PhD advisor Jim
- Carlos lab and basically you see those
are sort of model fit quality for
different kinds of models that came
before including some of my own and then
basically once we have deep Nets those
explained the data fit the data way
better than anything else and you know
this has been going on and basically the
bottom line is the better the models get
on image net the better the fit seems to
be between what's going what the
representational space looks like in the
in the deep net and what the
representational space seems to look
like in the population so this led to
this idea that well maybe maybe visions
just tapped out and this is a solved
problem and then maybe we don't need to
worry about this anymore the answer is
deep Nets there's a problem because all
the work we've done so far is all
looking at static representations and
really our visual systems are built for
dynamic situations and it's even worse
than that because even if you show a
static stimulus neuronal populations
will not produce static outputs and this
is one of the first things you notice
when you're a graduate students sticking
electrodes into the brain of the monkey
which I did for five years if you show a
static picture of a monkey face
you get these sort of transient
responses and in fact the only way to
drive a sustained response in an IT
neuron at the end of the ventral visual
pathway is to show a dynamic stimulus so
this is very much at odds with how cnn's
work because they have no intrinsic
notion of time you put in an input you
get an output it's a static thing so
something is clearly going on here and
there's all kinds of interesting rich
dynamics here where sometimes it's
sustained sometimes it's not sometimes
it looks like it might be oscillating so
we don't really have a good picture yet
of what that's all about and to that and
you know that part which seems really
salient isn't actually captured by
simple cnn's and it gets even weirder
than that too because there's this great
experiment by Karl Olsen's lab where he
showed successive presentations of image
image image image and in some cases the
the second image the B image was
predicted by the first image so b4
always happened after a4 and you saw
this a couple hundred times and b5 was
always seen after a5 showed a couple
hundred times and then basically you see
is you don't get a response to beef-up
before if it's preceded by a for does
that mean that the cell just doesn't
like b4
well no actually it will respond to b4
but only when it's preceded by a
different image so there's some kind of
higher-order temporal track
that's going on but again CNN's just
don't capture because they don't have
any intrinsic notion of time the other
thing too which i think is actually a
salient problem for deep learning is
that most of the datasets we have to
train these things you need tons and
tons and tons of data you know if you
want to train you know a dog detector
you need you know thousands and
thousands and thousands of dogs and
thousands and thousands of thousands of
things that aren't dogs and that's just
not the way we learned I don't sit down
for my daughter and shower dog dog dog
dog dog Cat Cat Cat Cat that's just not
the way it works in fact yeah we can
just do that experiment right now does
anyone know what this is raise your
hands if you do okay we have a few
electrical engineers in the audience
okay even though you've even though
you've only seen this for the first time
is it present in this image yes how many
in this image - how about that one yeah
but it's a little weird right so even
though you only saw one example you were
immediately able to determine what was
there you immediately an expert on this
kind of object that's called one-shot
learning and you know just if you need
more evidence that deep nets don't quite
work yet is anyone can anyone say what
this is it's actually Meret Oppenheim
it's called luncheon in fur but everyone
agrees it's a cup a saucer in the spoon
state of the art deep net says it's a
teddy bear and then it gets worse than
that even even when things are very
clear to the right object so this is a
state of the art our CNN detection
correctly detects this as a bird but you
just put a few objects in the don't
belong and it starts you know calls this
a cat says that's it you know it's this
is a television but so it's calling that
a cat so there's something about there's
something brittle and adversarial
examples we could go on and on and on
about ways in which deep nets really
aren't quite solving the problem yet and
you know the I I and other people think
that unsupervised learning is an
important piece of this so how can we
without labels gather up a lot of
structure about the world and build
representations that are really good and
then that can feed into things like
reinforcement learning and all that kind
of stuff so this is just a different
part of the stack I think we all agree
on there's multiple kinds of learning
happening here but the kind that I'm
really interested in and have been for a
long time is this idea of temporal
learning if you just look at the
environment and let it play out the
environment is almost always showing you
its structure so you look at a person
doing a tennis serve you can see how
they're articulated you can see
they're put together you can see how the
shadows move around on an object that's
just all played out in time
you don't need supervision you can just
observe and learn a lot about the world
so that's what we're interested doing it
and you know brains from the from the
neuroscience literature seemed to be
exquisitely tuned for these kinds of
temporal statistics so this is one of my
favorite studies it's like a physics
where basically they took faces and then
they rotated them and then had subjects
to passively watch these but as a little
trick sometimes they would morph the
face as it moved and people generally
didn't notice this but if you ask the
same different later ones that had
morphed and they had seen them morph a
few times they would incorrectly sort of
associate them as being the same same
object and then you can even go further
this is let me I didn't over my PhD you
can even have presented a peripheral
object and then have while the subject
is a Codding you flip it out for a
different object before their eyes land
their eyes land on a different object
and then you ask them to do same
different on peripheral versus fovea and
they'll make incorrect associations so
it seems like the brain is constantly
collecting up these sort of temporal
associations to make sense of the world
so we have we have experimental of us
this might be happening but we don't
have really models for it now there have
been prior attempts so slow Fourier
analysis is a is an attempt to sort of
extract those signals that are moving
slowly and this has been influential but
you know it hasn't sort of unleashed you
know a revolution in how we do things
but it's an interesting and important
set of ideas but what I want to do is
look specifically at prediction as an
unsupervised learning rule so basically
the idea that can we just use the idea
of predicting what a future frame is
going to look like to help us build
better representations and I'm gonna
make the argument that brains are
particularly adept at prediction I'm
gonna use this person who's this person
Sarina yes not Venus Sarina you guys are
our experts so anyway so she can she can
do tennis serve at 207 km/h that's 57
meters per second that means the ball
traverses the court in 400 milliseconds
about now the latency from the retina to
the primary visual cortex is about 60
milliseconds so that means that v1 is
operating 3 meters in the past and if we
go all the way through the ventral
visual hierarchy then we're talking
about about a hundred and seventy
millisecond latency in a human it's
about nine meters so there's a very deep
sense in which if you think you saw
Serena Williams's tennis serve you
couldn't have because your brain you
know this year
line latency of your brain was way in
the past so one suggestion that that's
been made is if you're returning that
serve a big part of what you're doing is
you're looking at the lined up and
you're predicting where the ball is
going to be and that's where you're
putting your racket so you know and this
this idea has been sort of you know it
can be shown there's a little bit of
nuance here but if this is called the
flash lag you lose inch so if you look
at this dot right here and then watch
this sort of clock hand going around you
see how there's like a little flashing
straight line now is that line behind in
front of or lined up with the clock hand
behind of course and the rule with all
optical illusions is if it looks like
it's not lined up it is lined up and if
it looks like it is lined up it's not
lined up so so this is perfectly
collinear
and the sort of classical interpretation
and there's some nuance here is that
basically this line has to go through
the full pipeline latency of the visual
system but this tracking line is
predictable so your visual your
perception just sort of puts it where it
really is in real time so so this is and
then there's another weird things
everyone's kind of see that it looks
like it's tilted as well I can just hold
that thought all right so so so so we
wanted to get into this so we were we
were you know working in sort of machine
learning computer vision and right
around the time we were working on this
we got interesting this idea of future
framed video prediction so basically the
idea is that if we see a sequence of
images transforming the goal is to
basically predict what the next image
looks like and this is now that there
were there was a little bit of work
around the time we were doing this and
that's it's a much bigger field now just
to acknowledge that there are other
people working in this area and we did
some very simple things that you would
do in in deep learning and again this is
sort of fits in the same spirit of what
Matt was talking about where so you just
want the simplest possible models to
start with and just see how much your
problem statement sort of you know sort
of it makes the problem happen so
basically we did is we took an
autoencoder type architecture and we
just wedged a recurrent neural network
in this case an LS TM in the middle and
then asked and then we also had a
fancier version with gans back then
there were only four Gann papers so it
seemed exotic and how there's like 4,000
Gann papers but anyway so basically what
we discovered is we can build these sort
of generative networks that could
actually basically sort of renderer
faces and this doesn't seem so
surprising anymore but at the time
I was shocked how well this worked and
there's some details about whether you
use the Gann or not and whether the ear
appears or not but the basic bottom line
is this is there a future frame video
prediction problem where we see a
sequence of frames and then we predict
what the next frame might look like it
is actually a tractable thing we can do
with neural networks now and then the
interesting and of course it works on
all kinds of different faces including
faces you haven't seen before but the
interesting thing here was we were
really trying to look at what kind of
representations do we implicitly induce
when we train a network to do this kind
of future frame prediction so all we're
training we're training the network with
back prop but the loss is coming
entirely from how well does it
reconstruct a future frame that it
hasn't seen before and the interesting
interesting thing that we find is if we
kind of just take that internal
representation and just sort of pipe it
off and just ask how well can we decode
things about other things like the
identity of the face what we find is if
we do a simple you know 50 Way face
recognition task where we need to tell
which of 50 people it is and we only get
to see 1 2 3 4 so on views of the person
what we see is if we start using these
predictive networks they're able to do a
little bit better with a little bit less
data and this is what we're trying to
get towards can we get representations
where we can do more with less training
data and because we're sort of
extracting some sort of sort of deep
part of you know some sort of deep
structure of the image now this was back
in in 2015 and then you know we also
discovered that you know for instance
you could internal within to these the
representations that we learned you
could also find directions that you can
move around in that would do things like
make the face more male or more female
these are less surprising now that
ganzar around and we can do all kinds of
fancy things with them but what we
really we're driving towards just to get
more to the punchline was not this sort
of very simple auto encoder with an RNN
in the middle but really getting towards
this idea of predictive coding which
came from neuroscience so the basic idea
here this is a paper from 1999 that
popularized predictive coding but the
idea actually goes back about a decade
earlier and the basic idea is this we
start with an input we have a
feed-forward signal we try and predict
away the input and we subtract that off
and we only send forward the differences
now the original idea here was an
efficient coding idea
let's try and reduce the number of
spikes we have to send because if we
subtract away the things we already know
then all we need to send forward is the
is the the difference from that so what
we did was basically to take yeah on
what we think the signal is if I'm
looking at the outside and I'm trying to
submit position of a ball and predicting
where the ball is going to be is a
different stories and if I'm trying to
estimate suppose it's octave all right
and then do in how many examples do we
actually know what it is that we're
trying to predict I mean really for sure
right this is only doing that thing
right yeah that's that's a great matter
question and and I think we can discuss
that like what are we estimating in this
case for the purposes of this we just
took the simplest path I mean again this
is sort of the modus operandi is take
the simplest possible thing and then see
where you get with it so here we're
actually gonna generate whole frames so
we actually want to confabulate and sort
of imagine what the future frames gonna
look like so you could imagine in that
flash lag illusion example you're
percept in that case is actually an
imagined thing it's like it you're
actually what you're perceiving at a
given moment is is a fabricated future
State so so we're gonna take it at the
pixel level but I agree because if you
were interests in different things you
might you might use different sort of
targets for your prediction but what we
did basically was to take the sort of
classic idea of predictive coding and a
state instantiated in the simplest
possible way we could with with deep
networks so basically what we do whose
inputs come in here we have a running
prediction of what the input should look
like and then we subtract them off to
get an error map and then we send that
forward to the next layer and then we
have a recurrent layer at each at each
stage of the hierarchy that's trying to
build up this prediction and it can get
feedback just the same as in the brain
and it can also get local recurrence and
then you basically just subtract off and
there's different ways you can do the
subtraction doesn't much matter and then
you get these errors you only send the
errors forward through the network so
one nice thing about this is at time one
this is a CNN as nothing's come through
so the extent that CNN's are a good
model for the ventral visual pathway
this is the CNN on the first time step
and then the other thing that's nice
about it is it's also a classic
generative model so if we put something
in on the top it'll render down into an
actual predicted image here so we can
see what the network is is seeing or
perceiving and I'm given
moment and we called we started off by
calling these particular works and then
we don't maybe deep prediction that's
not good name pretty deep no bill net no
can't believe it's not Alex net we ended
up with pregnant
because their rules their rules to how
you do this and you have to you know you
have to get them right so we're calling
these pred nets for better or for worse
and what we found is that these networks
that had the recurrence at every layer
we're able to you know our previous ones
were only able to get sort of one degree
of freedom and a rotating object now we
could actually get as many degrees of
freedom basically as we wanted in these
synthetic objects so here are examples
and basically that just for all these
I'm gonna show is this is the actual
sequence of incoming images and then
what's next but below it is the
time-shifted prediction so you can
compare the prediction to what actually
came and you can see on the first frame
you get these weird potato thinks as it
doesn't know which way it's going to go
but then once it knows which way it's
gonna go it locks on and then you start
getting pretty good predictions and it
can do this with faces it hasn't seen
before and all that kind of stuff but
again the the reason we're doing this is
not for future frame prediction per se
but to see if we can actually learn good
representations because the idea is in
order to predict what's coming next you
have to implicitly know lots of things
about the structure of the object how
light works how shadows work all that
kind of stuff
and what we find is basically if we try
and build decoders again in the same
sort of spirit as that face recognition
task where we just sort of peel off the
representation and just do linear
decoding we discover that we can decode
lots of different parameters of the
image like how fast it's moving what the
starting angle is we can also look at
things about principal components of the
identity so you it sort of fits with
this idea again that by virtue of
learning good predictions you learn good
representations that are useful for lots
of things which is kind of what you need
to have in an unsupervised or a
semi-supervised learning sort of setting
we also did a face-recognition version
of this again and what we found is that
these presents at least at the time were
performing on par better than the best
semi-supervised learning algorithms that
were available called latter networks so
you might wonder what happens if we put
in things that aren't faces what does it
do it actually does something pretty
reasonable so this is a network that was
trained on faces and we put in this
image of a top and you know something
came out pretty okay
it doesn't always turn out okay here's a
here's like a little toy car and you can
see it's desperately trying to turn it
into some kind of face it's like this
like when scream kind
trying to happen there but you know and
but the bottom line is if you train it
on complicated things and enough variety
you can get networks that can do pretty
good predictions on just about anything
you want to do and of course just about
anything you want to do is cars right
autonomous cars like at least in this
year we did this work that's the thing
you want to be doing prediction on
because that's where all the money is so
we took my student bill without any
prompting took some some car mounted
camera datasets so this we train it on
the kiddy data set which is in Germany
and then what I'm showing you here is
the test set which is the Caltech
pedestrian data set and then this is
what the predictions look like so
they're not perfect they're a little bit
blurry
if we put a Gann on it we can make it
less blurry sure but we're really just
focusing on sort of learning what kind
of representations we can pull out of
this and a couple interesting things
here one is it seems to implicitly know
a lot about perspective and flow it
knows that things need to expand
outwards and needs you knows the things
that are far away need to you know
change less it also knows to infill road
here if we look at other examples as
well you can see things like you know it
knows a little bit about occlusion so
this car is going to include this golf
cart it knows that that one should go in
front it knows you know it knows all
kinds of things about you know
implicitly about the flow of content in
the image and again what we're trying to
do here it's interesting to do it to
look at feature frame prediction and we
can also do farther out future frame
predictions as well if we can go out as
much as five frames it gets blurrier but
it's it's still okay but again the goal
here is to say well by virtue of
learning how to predict as sort of a
surrogate loss can we learn how to
decode other things that might be useful
and in a car one of the things you might
want to learn about is what's the
steering angle of the car and what we
find again in the same way we can take
the representation peel that off put it
into a linear decoder and we can
discover that without any prior training
on these steering angles this can
actually outperform a system that was
purpose-built to decode steering angles
so this is from comma this is a startup
that's doing autonomous cars they had a
reference CNN on their data set and then
basically the president just by learning
how to predict the future also
implicitly learned what the steering
angle of the car was
that was kind of what you need to do to
do the task yeah not one not just the
recurrency but also the fact that you're
training it on continuously sample
images representation is due to the
prediction as opposed to merely
the sequence of training images all
right so so we have so we've done
predictive versions and we've also done
sort of a just a autoencoder style and
the prediction outperforms the details
about are all in the paper how much
additional how much of a better
representation of you gain by adding the
predictive component as opposed to just
having from whatever image your sequence
of images you have you mean specifically
for this the steering angle version so
the way the the comma one works is it it
takes in frames and it puts them to a
CNN and it so it has the temporal
component but it doesn't have any notion
of prediction it wasn't it wasn't sort
of trained to do prediction and what we
see here is these were the comma
reference CNN's so how well they
performed and then this is with
different numbers of input frames to the
decoder and you can see it can can do
quite well with with relatively little
data so it seems to be a useful thing
but again what we're trying to do is
trying to drive towards how might this
be a principle that the brain could use
to organize itself yeah
when we're doing rollouts what do you
mean oh into the future so their unique
way school what we do is we re inject
recurrent recursively the the
predictions and then we fine-tune that
so so basically if you take the
prediction put it in again get the next
prediction put it in again put the next
prediction and you can get its it starts
to get blurrier and blurrier over time
but that's basically what we're doing
very briefly showed we can do five
frames ahead the predictions just get
murkier it makes a little bit of a
difference it gets murkier because you
don't know which way the car is going to
go
I mean realistic what we should be doing
what we are doing now is
probabilistically we should actually be
putting out a probability distribution
of all the possible outcomes and that's
that's hard but that's what we're doing
and you know there's a lot of
interesting sort of wrinkles but even
just with this but the straight up let's
just does this come up with a mean
outcome because there's a problem that
if you don't know it's gonna go left or
right then you you don't want to split
the difference and get blurry what you'd
really like to do is but have a system
that produces samples that are sort of
the correct distribution of actual
outputs you could have and again that's
something something we're working on
something brain publi does - of course
then we want to actually since this is a
neuroscience talk we want to go back and
look at like well does this do something
that explains something in neuroscience
that we didn't understand before well
here's something that everything does so
it turns out you get good bores
everything you know every neuron that
work you train on anything no matter
what you do it's like a rule that you'll
get Gabor is out and and orientation
tuning but more interesting than that is
this notion that I sort of flagged
earlier which is if you put in a static
input the brain doesn't give you a
static output it gives you a dynamic
output so there's usually a delay
there's a burst of activity and then you
have this sort of activity that falls
off and sometimes you also get off
responses so when the stimulus goes away
you get a fresh response and it's
probably not a great surprise but pride
nets do this as well and it's not hard
to see why so this is the average of
units in the error representation of the
pregnant
hard to figure out why it's doing this
basically what happens is on that first
hit it can't predict anything when the
first image first flash is on so you get
a big bunch of activity but then as it
locks on and learns to sort of explain
away the data then it goes down and then
when you get the image off that's
another sort of surprise and then you
get another burst of activity yeah if
you sprinkled the pixels randomly like
you know Toby Delbert's event cameras or
something true continue so so it's true
we're doing this in discrete time
because we're talking about worker L
STM's and things like that
convalesced hams so we can't accommodate
continuous time but I don't think that's
I don't think that's a huge huge
difference well I mean these aren't like
different frames it's like continuous
frames so it's a relatively smooth
progression through the space of images
and when you have nothing and then you
put on something that is the kind of
discontinuity we're talking about it is
in discrete time yeah so what we did is
we literally put the image up you know
blank screen put the image up and then
take the image off and so that's like
the standard sort of primate experiment
version of this and basically the
present that does exactly the same thing
has exactly the same dynamics that you
would find in in primary visual cortex
so this is this is a bit of
circumstantial evidence at least that
part sort of matches up with
expectations originally actually
particular coding was it was designed to
explain a phenomenon called N stopping
which is if you have a bar that's
oriented the way a v1 cell likes and
then you make the bar longer and longer
and longer and longer the response will
go up to some point and then once you
make it longer actually the response
gets suppressed so it's like too much of
a good thing you know the longer the bar
is that that's in the orientation that
likes it actually reduces the response
and you know true to form the the
present version of predictive coding
also has this sort of n stopping
response which which is a nice nice
thing to have but it goes further than
this there's also this notion of
surround depression so if you have a
stimulus which is a dot and you
larger and larger and larger and larger
the e1 cells will like it better and
better and better and respond more and
more and more up to a point but then
beyond that they'll start being
suppressed as if there's a suppressive
surround around the response and what we
find is that the the pet net also has
this quality so if you look in again the
bottom layer the response goes up to a
certain size of a dot stimulus and then
it's suppressed but interestingly Rick
borns lab at Harvard back in 2013 found
that if you cool downstream visual areas
so if you cool v2 and then record in v1
so in activate feedback connections you
actually would find that these surround
suppression effects were themselves
suppressed they go away if you take away
the top-down feedback and this is a way
easier experiment to do in in a network
because you can just turn off the
feedback connections and see what
happens and lo and behold you get almost
exactly the same pattern of feedback so
in the pred net sit extent there
surround suppression it's happening as a
top-down feedback phenomenon just the
same way it seems to be happening in the
primate and then you know as we sort of
march through these things we also have
this interesting sort of sequence
learning effects that you see in the end
of the ventral visual pathway and lo and
behold if you show it pregnant these
things so the pred Nets just trained on
natural images like our videos and then
we're gonna show it these stimuli that
are basically the same as what you would
find in these experiments in an
untrained pred net you get these sort of
funny effects where it's you know you
flash up an image and it takes a little
while to sort of predict it away but
then as you train these these sequences
so that are expected you get sharper and
sharper transitions from between these
images and then what happens is
basically the same exact result so if B
is predictable from a in serial
presentations again this is trained on
cars and then we just subsequently show
it a few of the you know a comparable
number hundreds of examples then B will
be suppressed if a explains away B but
if we show that very same B and you know
with something else that's not a that
doesn't predict it in front of it we get
the exact same result that the Carlos
and company got so it's able to track
with almost exactly the same number of
trials some of these interesting
sequence learning
facts with no no extra machinery needed
to be added and then you might also ask
okay that that flash lag illusion so you
might remember you know this this clocks
going around this bar is flashing it's
actually lined up but it looks like it's
lagging behind so you might ask
oh is that this is the same thing happen
with with the pred net and the cool
thing about generative neural networks
is you can see what they're experiencing
because we can just visualize the error
layer and so this is what it's seeing
now there's a caveat here does anyone
know the caveat is yeah yeah so you're
getting a double dose so so the network
is seeing it and then you're seeing it
on top of what the network is seen so if
we really want to do this we need to we
need to look at freeze frames and we can
see exactly what what the network's
seeing and there it is there's that
weird lagging and there's the tilt too
right that was weird
there wasn't a good there wasn't a
satisfy satisfy explanation for that
tilt before and it just sort of falls
out of the pregnant yeah just
predictable on a longer time scale yeah
so it's the same thing with with with
the human version of it right like it's
predictable but there seems to be some
window beyond which it's not it's
effectively not predictable that's right
there's also weird things like you see
these like weird ripoli things happening
and I don't know what those are but
they're really cool and I like looking
at them and we'll figure out what
they're for eventually and then I love
the scientific community and I love
archive so we posted this and a group in
Japan picked it up and started using it
so they basically wanted to see these
illusory motion stimuli they wanted to
see what would happen if they showed
them to pred nuts so so the way these
work hopefully you're experiencing the
illusion right now this is a static
image but it looks like these are are
sort of these ones are sort of are sort
of rotating and these ones are not so
this is a classic you know sort of
illusory motion sort of stimulus and it
turns out if you if you train a pret net
on these sort of rotating so it's seen
real objects rotating in the world or
synthetic images of like propellers and
things moving in the world and then you
compute the flow vectors on the actual
predictions
if you just let a pregnant look at these
static images the pregnant actually
produces flow vectors that are
consistent with the illusion so when
humans see the illusion the pregnant has
optic flow that looks like what we see
and when humans don't see the illusion
there's no optic flow so so this is this
is interesting especially because the
usual explanation for these things has
to do with sort of epiphenomena about
the relative Layton sees visual
responses and now that might still be
true but this at least gives you another
possible explanation which is that you
have a system that's trained with the
predictive loss it's gonna naturally
have some of these biases that come from
the sort of statistics of the world so
with all things neural network you know
like we just hide all the like the
parameter search that went into it there
is indeed so the failure mode in general
when it can't when it doesn't learn so
if we have like the hyper parameters
wrong or whatever is that it predicts
the last frame that's usually our
benchmark against which to see if it's
working so we take the reconstruction
lost if you just said it's the same as
the last frame and then compare how much
we improve the error and then you're
right it if it's too herky-jerky then it
has trouble learning so so I don't have
a good quantitative answer for you but
there there is indeed a sweet spot and
yeah I mean it depends on how fast you
run the framerate we were running these
at 10 frame frame rates so that's kind
of yeah
about about 100 milliseconds it depends
on how fast things are moving as well so
anyway so I promised that we would get
back to a neuroscience experiment so I'm
going to tell you about a story about an
actual neuroscience experiment that the
neuroscience said the wet lab part of my
lab did in response to the computational
work that was going on in my lab so you
might remember that we could read out
the steering angle from a self-driving
car using the internal representations
in the pregnant we also had the idea
well you know wouldn't it make sense to
actually take the efference copy of the
steering wheel all the odometry of the
car we could just feed that into the
representation surely the network would
do a better job of predicting so if I'm
trying to predict how the world is going
to change if I know the wheels turn this
way I can make a better prediction about
how the world's going to change I might
also be able to do cool things like if I
could sort of fictive Li imagine like
conditionally generate if I turn the
wheel like this what would the world
look like so this is something we
started doing just because it made sense
from a machine learning standpoint and
no big surprise when you don't have a
friend's copy which is basically the
sort of vanilla pret net you get certain
convergence over time you know so you
get get down to some mean error and with
with training epoch but if you include
this extra information unsurprisingly
the network converges faster and comes
up with a better result so that's that's
all fine and good but if this were true
and this is what was happening in the
brain that would imply that in visual
cortex we should have signals from motor
cortex right they should be there and if
they're there we should be able to
decode them even in the dark potentially
so so my student Greg thought this was a
great idea he was doing 24/7 recordings
in visual cortex in a rat at the time so
he's had boatloads of boatloads of data
so we just had that lab meeting well hey
well I just put them in a dark box like
so there's no light completely
light-tight and see if you can actually
and you have an accelerometer on the
animal's head anyway because you know
the minute you're putting electrodes and
you might as well put an accelerometer
in there too and then so we can record
from from many tête roads so we have you
know 60 16 tetrode 64 electrodes and we
can record local field potentials and
then we also have
these accelerometer signals so there's a
there's a hypothesis that comes from the
computational work that says well we
should be able to decode you see friends
copy signals in you know potentially
even in v1 and it turns out that that is
exactly what we can do so so these blue
bars are in complete darkness and visual
cortex so there's no visual stimulus
they're not getting any visual optic
flow but we can decode a little bit of
you know sort of six degree of freedom
information about which way the animals
nose is pointing and then interestingly
if you inject mute samal into area M two
which is the putative place where these
motor signals you friends copies would
be coming from you know this is all
still new so you know don't get futzed
if this ends up not holding up because
we still only get more animals at least
in the first animal we did we can
actually abolish that signal so if we
take away motor cortex signals we
actually can't any longer decode the
position of the animal's head in 3-space
so this is a case where we actually
built them up we built a model that was
useful in its own right it helped
explain some things about neuroscience
more or less along the way without
having to fit anything and then by
looking at it we can make predictions
which then led to experiments that we
could do to maybe learn something new
about how the brain is organized
corollary discharged we can't tell and
in an electrophysiology we just have
some Tet Rhodes recording from some
places and we're not exactly sure where
we can't reconstruct the image to fully
disambiguate that we also have two
photon imaging going on in my lab so
there is an idea that we could go and be
getting you know hundreds of cells that
are thousands of cells at a time you
know
and have a prayer of actually doing
those those decoding experiments and
that's work that we have that's the song
going but but you know right now we're
just in the stage where we said can we
decode any information and the answer
seems to be yes I agree there's a lot of
questions that come downstream of that
like well you know predictive coding
implies certain kinds of correlational
structures that we can start to look at
we also have the ability to image
synapses in the two-photon image of the
synapses differently separately from the
cell body so we can actually look at
feedback synapses specifically and ask
how the information that they contained
is different than the the cell bodies in
layer 2 3 so these are all experiments
that are ongoing but I don't have a good
answer for you but that's the right kind
of question and that's the right kind of
question we can ask you know when we
have these kinds of models they can
guide our experiments ok so this is my
pitch so apparently a deep mind it's a
it's a circle for me it's just a it's
just a ping-pong I don't know I like the
circle better maybe I'll change it top
away oh yeah that's right
so people are picking this up Gooding
neuroscientists and we love that if you
want to pick it up there it is the codes
all free I'm told it's not hard for
other people to get working so that's
great that's a testament to Bill's hard
work to share things so I just want to
try and get us back on schedule so this
is my lab just went to acknowledge
everyone particularly Bill water and
then all the people who funded this
stuff and then just one shameless plug
you know so I've just started as the
director of this institute if you're
interested in sort of AI and
neuroscience Nexus the kinds of stuff
that I'm showing you here and you
reached in doing that in industry you
know find me during one of the breaks
I'd be happy to talk right thanks
[Applause]
yes oh the most of the mud so the motor
modulation it's there's a whole cottage
industry of like my son trackballs when
they run versus when they don't run and
and basically there's more information
about whether the running or not then
there seems to be about the visual
system that's sort of like a first
approximation but but a lot of the
there's been a sort of a dichotomy of
people who are either either think you
know maybe this is a predictive process
and kind of thing versus people who
think it's more of like an arousal sort
of like when the animals running they're
on and when they're not running they're
off or something and you can probably
imagine which one I think is the more
likely scenario and so so so the idea
that we can actually get information
about the actual direction the nose is
pointing I think is interesting and a
little bit surprising and and feels like
at odds with the idea that it's just
sort of an on versus an off kind of
transformation now in terms of
vestibular signals yeah I mean we're
we've talked about you know the you know
the experiments aren't pretty but you
can imagine what they're like you know
it's like I'm just moving I'm moving the
rat in the dark Here I am with my rat
moving in the dark so you know like
sometimes this thought you have to do
the science and and it's not it's not
glamorous so we say so so we aren't in
those experiments I mean it doesn't sort
of go against the general theme here
like wherever you get the signals from
you'd be crazy not to use them I think
the fact that we see some reduction in
them when we knock out em to suggest a
little bit that maybe it's more of a
motor you friends copy but it's entirely
possible that this tabular system the
vestibular inputs are getting through to
v1 through
so m2
is I mean it's like it's sort of like
frontal orienting fields in a monkey
it's like an orienting area yeah so as
near as we can tell it doesn't seem to
so we've done let's go to all the
marginal comparisons so you'd expect it
to have some effect it turns out you can
actually just scoop out all of them fun
all the motor cortex by my neighbor at
Harvard Ben selves Eskie did this
experiment are you basically just carpet
bomb all of motor cortex and the animals
can still do all kinds of complicated
motor tasks so that that's alarming if
you study motor cortex but but from our
perspective it's it's actually a good
things I mean so it's near as we can
tell we're not changing with the
statistics of the movement one of things
were moving towards mister is trying to
get more quantitative predictions about
what would the actual predictive
coatings that are subtractive having a
model at least gives you a prayer of
being able to sort of ask those kinds of
questions I agree it's complicated it's
not at the end not the end-all be-all
and and also in monkey and primate IT
there was there some beautiful studies
that were they were kind of lesser-known
where they showed that in complete
darkness they were psychotic eye
movement signals presence he could
decode when cicadas happened so so these
ideas aren't aren't new it's just for
their sort of driving us in new
directions
[Music]
but when you're comparing that to the
neural state law of attraction the first
example if you're showing if you're
comparing that to the N stopping signals
or the transient dynamics yeah it turns
out if you look at them they almost all
look the same which which is
disheartening for people who want to
disambiguate different populations I
mean at least when you marginalize them
in this way the the e neurons look like
pop and then off response but so did the
activation neurons and so there are
recurrent neurons that are sort of
sitting there and like like in Matt's
talk like they're ones that are doing
the things you know they have to be
doing but there are ones in the in the
recurrent layer that also have the sort
of transient dynamics as well so so the
long story is like if you were sticking
electrodes into a monkey brain like I
did for five years you know you wouldn't
know which ones of these you were
getting and they all look surprisingly
similar I mean so in the in the cases
where we're doing the cutting we're
actually decoding from the ours so but I
mean you you can decode lots of things
from lots of places the arse
we thought the arse made a lot of sense
because they're the ones who should be
holding information about context and
representation but I mean there's
obviously a lot going on yeah as you get
further along though this is a CNN in
the static case on the first time step
because you basically there's nothing to
cancel out this is all zeroes so you
just go up through like a CNN so you
would expect there to be sort of
different levels of representation of
higher level and lower level features so
it's only long story short it's
complicated the the simple fact of
training it in this predictive mode is
gonna affect all of these weights so
it's going to induce representations
even in these A's so the bottom line is
like you can pretty much decode from
anywhere this is bad news for
Neuroscience right you can decode from
anywhere and all of them qualitatively
look very similar in their dynamics
so I think about the relationship
between what you're doing here and the
stuff that I've been working on but
honestly really the ideas that were put
forth by hoc right originally about
supervise and that work would suggest
that this system should be able to do
something even richer which is to do
something like visual system
identification so in the phenomena that
you've you've talked about you look at
the first frame and you can make
predictions about what's going to happen
because you live in this world but there
are situations where I can't predict
this observing the dynamics helps me
predict the dynamic so if I like let me
say it's seeing or someone with a fuse
joint or something should be able to do
that kind of system identification on
the I don't know but I agree and we're I
think we're all kind of using the same
market fuel right it's like Ellis TMS
can do a lot and these are sort of two
separate instantiations of like
recurrent Nets can can actually do do a
lot yeah exactly exactly exactly and and
there is a spot that you know they even
after you fix things and it's running
you know it has state that's that it's
accumulating so it can you can do I
think system identification so I mean
this isn't this isn't fit exactly into
your what you're talking about but we
also had it doing things like predicting
balls bouncing around and things like
that and you know and it works you know
like the balls bounce off the walls yeah
and if we have these like have like
electrostatic repulsion or something
you could imagine them learning
dynamically like well you know this is
this is the new rules so yeah and this
is the kind of setting I would probably
prefer to do it in rather than the other
one cuz you can't control the natural
world as easily but but I think it's
really interesting I mean that there are
limits of the capacity of this thing to
learn so it you can't you know if you
have very complicated movies and things
it doesn't do a great job of predicting
the next frame so we've far from crack
the nut but it just feels like we're
kind of moving maybe a little bit in
right direction
so so much like the project I spent 20
years of my life working I've had so
many people tell me that it ultimately
got published at nips as unsupervised
pixel prediction and it was just trying
to predict a moving dot no recognition
of anything it was only doing the motion
different continuity in time I wrestled
with it it was awful it worked kind of
okay yeah yeah while I was working as a
coder and an algorithm guy and stuff in
Silicon Valley what some C++ and a job I
worked at Redwood Neuroscience but
ultimately what happened was I rely I
alternate Lee gave a presentation here
that it worked with just using matrices
and just the algorithms forget the
neurons it was that hard then I throw
away even the matrices and finally got a
zero parameter model where I just
assumed volumetric 3d computational
medium intracellular space so if you
assume brains just do 3d computations I
so I understand I think I think we
understand continuity in time and it's
just what he said yeah
but trying to build it on top of deep
learning which was built around
essentially n dimensional hyperspace all
we have to do with 3d continuous it's
not easier oh this is a soft key in fits
paper is that the one I think I think I
think we I mean I think we I think we
saw I think we cited you but the I think
I think I think the you know the tools I
mean the thing that's nice about deep
learning and maybe others have this sort
of intuition about it it sort of nice to
be able to say here's our like I'm
saying like presto magico deep-learning
what I'm saying like I think we've
gotten to the stage where but that's all
abstraction now what we can say is if we
just optimize future frame prediction
what else obtains and I think that's the
right framing for using deep learning to
sort of it's not that we're like doing
neurons or that they are neurons like
this has back prop like clearly you know
like there's gonna be a couple
suggestions on how we can do it better
it's more like if you just optimize this
one thing and deep learning lets you
very effectively optimize that one thing
this is what comes out of it right so
that that's kind of the mode we're
thinking about it and you know could it
be reduced to some other simpler thing
sure but we just wanted to have the
tools that take us to there to that to
that point and I think we're I think
we're out of time unfortunate this or
that feature of object this is the kind
of work you did in your thesis and your
adviser certainly you know should not
fire at all if it's correctly
representing this thing and so I'm
trying to picture how the same room can
be both representing something and
they're not representing something and
and the question is maybe the answer is
in that your last picture when you said
so on the first pass to reader model
basically the representational kind of
thing is getting passed forward through
these error units which are the only
things passing anything for which is a
pretty strong constraint in their model
and so but then later those same units
must be passing forward something it
means something different which is you
know the the non predictive part only
those are two very different things at
very different at different times and so
are you is that the correct correct
interpretation which is the sort of
there's a time multiplexing where maybe
a first pass through the ventral
Strait is the representational pass and
could lead to successful recognition of
an object and then later that thing is
somehow shut off because everything is
predictable or what have suggested time
multiplexing in the responses before so
there's a paper from from yesterday's
group I could be wrong about that where
they're basically claiming that the
initial pop of activity had different
information than the latter part I would
say when when when Jim and I have said
in the past that this neuron represents
that thing we're taking time like cat
spike counts within 100 millisecond
window after you know 100 milliseconds
after onset of stimulus that that same
neuron is categorically not doing that
100 milliseconds after that right like
you know there's this weird phenomena
that a lot of the neurons are shut down
so I think this idea that these neurons
the firing of these neurons signal that
you know without any further additional
context I think that that kind of has to
be wrong that's on the level I mean the
fact that these things are so dynamic I
think the end of the day all the system
cares about is that makes the right call
and initiates the right behavior I don't
think is any requirement that there be
labeled line neurons that signal
features but so this is an example where
you have neurons that will look that way
if you if you look at them through that
lens but though but I think the reality
of the situation is quite a bit more
complex and I agree it's unsettling
confronted
[Applause]